hi i'm eric and i'm the general sales
manager here at move for less
and today we're helping uh michelle and
her husband brian mel
out for the moving our community program
uh they were
our newest recipient for the program and
it's definitely an honor to help you all
out
and get you on to uh your new homes and
uh
you know just i know that you guys have
been affected by coven
and it's been a hardship on you so us
having the resources to be able to help
it's a great honor so
unfortunately the owner decided to sell
the place that we lived in for about six
years
which again and then the week after that
my husband lost his job
which is very sad and unfortunately we
are going to have to live in two
different dwellings
not together so very sad
you don't really know how to tell my
daughter she has autism spectrum
disorder so
it's going to be very trying we came out
to help them out get into
the new location as well as having some
items into storage
and this is part of our moving our
community program which we started back
when the pandemic
hit to help individuals and families
uh during this time of need when they've
been affected due to the pandemic
for many different reasons whether he
lost a job lost a loved one
it could be a medical condition uh
anything like that where
we wanted to reach out and help
community or people within the community
so we
we've been in the las vegas community
for over 15 years now
and las vegas has been so good to us and
we wanted to find out
find different ways we can get involved
and help out we saw that
through from clovid people were gonna
have to move and a lot of it was gonna
be out of their control
it was gonna be because uh like this
situation the owners were selling the
home
uh maybe they lost uh one uh of the
people lost their job
a lot of cases both people lost their
job we knew the best way we could help
was to provide the moving services
and uh packing services storage if
needed and this is the best way that we
can help out relieve that kind of stress
monetary stress as well as the stress of
just getting getting the move done and
um this was really the best avenue
that we could do thank you so much i
just cannot thank you guys enough
for helping us out it was such a relief
to
have something good happen to us with so
much negative going on in our lives